tsm's league team is cursed they're
going for darus who pops his ultimate in
there gets the three-man oh no
knocks them all away but candy panda is
still fighting this one they want dyrus
they'll get him as well against the
tower he was knocked and there is
amazing now finding freddie who will
lock him up will freddie be able to
escape this one great dodging with the
ward i think that freddie might get it
and will not just save him but guess the
kill as well over the years fans
realized that no matter who they were no
matter how good they were going into the
team tsm's all-star junglers were doomed
to fail as people like to say harry
potter and defense against the dark
teacher position where you get replaced
every season tsm has featured some of
the biggest names in western league
history hell they're one of the biggest
teams in league of legends but their
carries have always been the stars of
the show what
i'm seeing i'm doing trying to defend
their swans are getting low but they
might be able to fight it out double
lift gets one can he make it to hoonie
now the next target the culling is just
that is the double in there doublelift
gonna go crazy the 1v3 solo gets himself
the triple i mean it's in the name right
it's team solomid they are a very
mid-centric team a very carry-centric
team and everything else has to pivot
around those carries that's how it was
for years and now as tsm's jungle has
become a revolving door of wasted talent
everyone's wondering the same thing what
the hell keeps happening to tsm's
junglers
all right folks before we get into the
video i just want to remind you all to
please sub to the channel and turn on
notifications if you haven't done it yet
because it really does help okay so
between 2014 and 2020 that's 14 splits
tsm went through eight different
junglers all but one of these eight
played just two splits or less and some
even had to share time but it's not like
these junglers were all untested or
disappointing some of them even earned
accolades before joining or even while
they were on the team and after leaving
many built successful careers elsewhere
as fenscaren told travis gaffer just the
culture in c9 is very different where
we're just more trying to improve and
when we do end up losing it's more like
we just go over why we lost and we're
not really mad at each other anyway you
slice it tsm's junglers are cursed while
they're on the team they are endlessly
scrutinized and as soon as they leave
everyone changes their mind about them a
lot of fans as well they just like
i might respect me more now for some
reason i don't really get it just
defense they go from one day they hate
you and the next day they love you so
it's kind of like surprising for me but
is this curse actually real well to find
out we have to go way back tsm's first
ever change in the jungle came in 2014
when danishjungler amazing replaced the
odd one joining his countryman bjergsen
on the revamped roster and amazing got
off to a rough start they got a good
amount of damage down the exhaust hits
on there's amazing over the wall he's
completely out of mana in that
engagement so he's gonna go down oh
they're just gonna be disabled and then
cleared out afterwards but we'll get
back there spencer are actually going to
jump in dyrus is off the back so he
needs to be careful look at the door
he comes over the wall and candy panda
is waiting despite a rebound that saw
tsm make it all the way to world's
quarter quarterfinals that year amazing
was off the roster for 2015. at the time
everyone was certain that bjergsen the
team's new mid laner was going to be the
future of tsm but what about the future
of tsm's jungle position enter santorin
another promising danish player who
signed with dsm for 2015. now this is
when [ __ ] really hit the fan while tsm
won spring split and playoffs in 2015
santorin even earned rookie of the split
internationally the team failed what can
tsm do aside from run and cry and lick
their wounds santorin gonna be the last
one to go down as diaries is already
somewhere else on the map see santorin
made his name on carry style junglers
like elise and lee sin but he wasn't
playing those champions on tsm and he
looked like a different player how well
impactful did right there right he had
four kills before going down he is every
single kill on his team saint vicious
not the right spot though a little
overground picked up the knockout to
impactful and now buddy fupu's not
exactly the right spot ziggs bomb comes
out a second kill grabbed up and ca one
more time force run but there comes
rocks done up by chris but there's the
rest of the team flashing away santorum
is around can he land the queue yes he
doesn't actually
do the flame breath rox picking up
another one three to zero both junglers
in this top lane now they're going
aggressive yeah the 2v2 matchup helios
is here as well but he's the squishy
catholics look at so much damage wow
kicked in the head as well enoch's now
here by himself and miracle now with he
manages to get it but miracle with a
double kill enoch's answering one when
tsm reached worlds he was told he needed
to do a lot more for his team you got to
make the calls you gotta like
basically do the entire early game first
like just like the way you communicate
what you want to play for that kind of
stuff and i had never done anything like
that before his time with dsm left
santorin shaken so much so that he
didn't just leave tsm he said he was
leaving league of legends entirely
losing a jungler that won rookie of the
split after just one year probably
should have been a wake-up call but it
was easily overshadowed by bjergsen's
emergence as one of na's greatest
midlaners and that meant that whoever
jungled next for tsm had to be ready to
support that mid-focused playstyle and
the team's penchant for invading second
blue buff even though that broke opened
the game a lot the tsm and also gave
them a reputation for really strong mid
laners because obviously they were
having a mid lane that had a blue buff
advantage but because of that
restrictive set if you throw any jungle
into that mix over time the team will
always end up going back to this very
binary playstyle in the early game which
made them very easy to scout which made
them easy to play against
internationally but tsm's jungler curse
truly cemented itself with their next
pick for the position svenskaran sven
was best known for his ability to always
carry even when his team left him
without any resources oh vaudags and
kick us in a little bit of trouble
there's a lot of support
this is three versus three lantern comes
out spin follows through six zero two
sven skirt is unstoppable seven zero two
what he did was understand when lane
advantage would lead to a map side
advantage and so he could invade solo
off of that right his lane doesn't have
to do anything just had to maintain
priority and he would understand that
now he was insurmountably ahead of the
enemy jungler and he was acquiring
resources in the enemy's jungle which
was denial for them yeah come spin can
you land the sonic wave i'm willing to
bet that he can he's got flash available
he connects follows in we do not see the
kill going out yet ignite is burning
friends gearing gets one he'll sign the
heel to the fly because forgiven heals
him keeps him up
this is game two all over again spence
guerin has got the biggest backpack in
europe and he's putting sk in it the
ability to thrive by consuming the
enemy's jungle seemed like a good fit on
paper and svenskeren was tsm's longest
serving jungler but despite some highs
things didn't work out
see while tsm won three nalcs
championships in a row they wanted
international success and
internationally the svenskaran era was a
disaster royal never give up make it out
of the group and send tsm back north
america's hopes shift to tomorrow and
cloud nine
agony in defeat here for tsm
again
out in group stages in worlds 2017. sven
scaron on tsm wasn't the same player as
he was before joining the team and that
might be because he was being asked to
do things he never needed to do before
everything that allows fence kevin to
just 1v9 carry on sk gaming no longer
existed for different reasons at
different stages but they no longer
existed the key characteristics and
champion pool is not the first thing i
think of but during the bjergsen double
lift and even before that era jungler's
played for lanes lanes never played to
enable junglers and since scone is a
jungle away if you're not using your
laners to enable your jungler it's a
waste you may as well get someone else
and so after another international
disappointment in 2017 the fans were
once again ready to blame the jungler
the whole human ward meme was in full
effect with bjergsen even lightheartedly
tweeting about it so whether it was
because he couldn't deal with the haters
or because he didn't like playing a
style that didn't suit him so then
skeren was off tsm by the end of 2017.
so to give you insight right a lot of
tsm's issues are are shot calling
communication
and we put a huge emphasis on it um on
specific players and you know
and
no matter how much we tried we couldn't
solve it and that's why we decided to
make changes unsurprisingly those
changes didn't help if anything the next
few years only proved that tsm's jungle
really was cursed first came mike young
a carry jungler fresh off an exciting
rookie the split performance speed does
get them get there a little bit quicker
and this might be the last push onto
this in inhibitor turrets can i try it
for what he wants and he gets back to
the front line they've found him and
samus has gone mike young cannot do
wrong this game he's gonna have like
difficult challenges because he's like a
carry focus jungler but i think that
with his mindset and the way he thinks
about the game he can definitely fix
that clutch gaming will be the first
organization to deny them their pass to
the semis and will earn their spot in
miami then after only playing a single
split mike was sent down to academy and
replaced by greg for summer as a whole
2018 was the worst year in the
organization's history with no domestic
titles and no international appearances
there might be some tsm chance at worlds
but they're only going to be for irony
is they have not made it this time a
wrist issue for greg saw acadian step in
in 2019 before they were both told they
would share time in the summer but
neither played the last week of the
split or the playoffs as they were both
suddenly replaced by academy jungler
spika despite us trying to figure out a
jungler between greg and acadian
going to be eight it felt like we had no
synergy with either of them and
spika was training up pretty well in
academy
so
it made way more sense for our
organization to try him out than
continuing a process that just wasn't
working tsm's jungler position was now a
revolving door of former rookies of the
year academy promotions and time
splitters the team's results weren't
good and it didn't seem like the issues
were going to get resolved anytime soon
expectations were pretty low and even
with spika in the jungle tsm once again
missed worlds what a team fight what a
game what a series clutch gaming three
to one knock down tsl
now as fun as it would be to deep dive
into the rest of tsm's jungler history
including a brief fling with dardoch
before bringing spika back from academy
it's time to talk about the future
because after the 2020 season was done
bjergsen retired to coach tsm before
returning to play mid for team liquid in
2022 former tsm junglers repeatedly
vouched for bjergsen saying they
respected him and that he was great to
work with and it's not like we have any
reason to doubt them hell the jungler
waiting for bjergsen on team liquid was
santorin yes the same santorin who said
he was going to quit competitive league
after playing for tsm which obviously
didn't happen and now that these two
players are reunited on a different team
it's pretty clear that bjergsen isn't
directly responsible for the curse and
sure tsm standing for talon suppression
machine might have been a fun meme
the town suppression is already
beginning i mean it's just unbelievable
but it's really okay but as more and
more of tsm's former junglers went to
worlds actually made it out of groups
there and earned mvp performances
domestically it felt true
it means a lot to me because i was stuck
in groups for four years straight in
some cases you probably can blame
inexperience for some of tsm's jungle
struggles but a lot of these junglers
really did flourish on teams that
weren't tsm i think though that no
matter what kind of pics you choose
there are things around the map that tsm
expects you to do
right
and there are things you won't have on
the map that other teams might be more
willing to adapt to you having the
reason why tsm continue to sign carry
junglers and then always chalk up their
performance issues to communication is
still a mystery one theory is that the
problem lies with reginald tsm's
notorious founder and former midlaner
who continue to have a huge influence
over the orcs decisions throughout the
years the fact that the entire
organization is owned by somebody who
interferes a lot in particularly roster
moves
this guy's not a jungler it's not a top
laner who's not idk he's not support
like this guy sees what's best for a
season two mid laner and i wonder how
much that kind of guy having veto
has impacted these
decisions that are just misplaced
they're just misplaced they don't they
betray a lack of a complete
understanding of the game but maybe the
narrative can finally change spika is
still tsm's jungler well literally every
other player a lot of the staff and even
their philosophy on domestic success has
changed spika has great mechanics and
actually came up through the tsm system
while he won mvp in summer 2021 he's now
trying to shock call in two languages
it's fair to say that there's plenty of
pressure on speaker's shoulders right
now dsm taking the drake down to about 1
000 it is secured by spika yet again the
boys got the smites where they need to
be impact's approaching from the side
boonies able to stop him giuzuke looking
for some of the lockdown but he only
finds it onto sword art who's already
stuck back in the ulti here ignard
coming in definitely legendary and
huni's already gone tsm fighting back
but cloud9 is bringing in reinforcements
tp's on the way hoonie's likely to die
here next double kill back over to fudge
blabbers stays alive he keeps on tapping
shut down over to summit tactical is
down tsm is crushed and cloud nine win
the fight spka's the only one that's
able to save this from being a baron for
cloud9 ultimately a jungler can be a lot
of things it's one of the deepest most
complex roles in a league every player
has the freedom to approach the jungle
in completely different ways it seems
like that freedom wasn't always there
for tsm's junglers but now with the
roster facing massive uncertainty it
might be that they have too much and
whether they use that freedom to chart a
new course for the team and break their
so-called jungler curse or to invade
second blue buff again the fans will
certainly be watching for any signs
whether they're hopeful
or cursed
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tick tock